moi j'aime bien les animals renaud
chante l'enfance dans les douze titres
de son nouvel album les mômes et les
enfants d'abord un thème cher au
chanteur depuis le début de sa carrière
dans les années 70 il chantait déjà les
révoltes les désillusions et les espoirs
de la jeunesse française
les jeunes surtout les jeunes des
milieux urbains se reconnaissent en
connaissent leur langage et leur
préoccupation
les faits divers que chanter ils sont
tous vécu ce que chante plus ou moins et
ils le ressentent bien parce que je
pense le exprimé dans leur langage et
leur langage c'est l argot un
vocabulaire de la rue que renault défend
des auprès de ces jeunes blouson noir on
doit la rose et c'est pas bidon tu crois
aux parades pour la roue pour moi il est
plus qu'une seule façon de dire qu'un
truc et c'est formidable
les dernières saisons vers le ca bègles
c'est cool ça craint pas employer les
mots du dictionnaire pour dire qu'un
truc est super et pour certains jeunes
les mots de renault devenait parfois un
nigma ville par des cons ils forment ce
n'était pas vraiment viré mais qui se
prenait pour des hommes
j'ai chanté une fois cent fois j'ai
hurlé pendant des mois j'ai crié sur
tous les toits
ce que je pensais de thouars société en
1984 pour ce jeune homme
renault faisait même partie de ses
maîtres à penser pour moi on nous ment
chanteur préféré
j'ai beaucoup pris exemple sur lui
d'ailleurs c'est pas elle qui m'a éduqué
d'accord mais ça me donne une certaine
idée de
la société une parole de la jeunesse que
renault portait aussi auprès des
politiques en soutenant la candidature
de françois mitterrand à la
présidentielle de 1988
le chanteur lançait un appel à tous les
jeunes français c'est important que la
jeunesse retrouve ce qu'elle a perdu à
savoir sa capacité d'indignation
domination au grand injustice qui se
passe en france l'espace dans le monde
la jeunesse l'enfance ou encore partie
des thèmes de prédilection du chanteur
les aujourd'hui c'est avec une certaine
nostalgie qu'il évoque dans quoi c'est
douloureux être pensé à son enfance bas
le temps perdu ne qui reviendra pas les
belles années d'insouciance de la
jeunesse de l'enfance
[Musique]